copie y pegue esta pregunta de los
ejercicios en khan academy dice ordena
las expresiones de menor a mayor
basándote en el rectángulo de abajo así
que necesitamos averiguar cuánto vale
jay-z y equis y después ordenarlos
entonces primero analicemos allí ahora
aquí salió un poco contraintuitivo pues
están usando la variable y para
representar a la coordenada x en este
punto entonces veamos si podemos
averiguar cuánto vale la coordenada x en
este punto
observa lo siguiente aquí tenemos un
rectángulo la coordenada x en este punto
tendrá el mismo valor que la coordenada
x en este punto pues está sobre la misma
línea vertical entonces si este punto
tiene una coordenada de x igual a 4
quiere decir que éste tendrá una
coordenada de x igual a 4 observe que
estamos utilizando la letra g para la
coordenada x puede resultar un poco
extraño pero es un simple cambio de
nombre así que este es el punto 47 por
lo tanto y es igual a 4 ahora veamos que
podemos averiguar de z observa que z es
la coordenada y z es la coordenada y en
este punto que otro punto tiene la misma
coordenada en jr
bueno pues será un punto que tenga el
mismo nivel por decirlo así
es decir estará en el mismo nivel en la
dirección vertical estará sobre la misma
línea horizontal entonces tendrá la
misma coordenada y este punto tiene
coordenada e igual a 3 por lo tanto éste
tiene coordenada e igual a 3 o podemos
decir lo que es lo mismo que z es igual
a 3 z es igual a 3
y ahora por último necesitamos saber
cuál es el valor de x ahora aquí resulta
que xy es la coordenada la coordenada x
aquí no habrá ninguna confusión
entonces x es la coordenada x para este
punto y la coordenada x en este punto
tendrá el mismo valor que la coordenada
x en este punto que es igual a 2 observa
que están sobre la misma línea vertical
están sobre la línea x igual a 2 por lo
tanto x es igual a 2
aquí sí coincidió en x que la coordenada
que estamos buscando es x ajá entonces x
es igual a 2 ahora recuerda que se nos
pide ordenar de menor a mayor
x es igual a 2 entonces x es el menor x
es igual a 2 luego z luego y así que 2
luego 3 luego 4 lo haré en el ejercicio
y comprobemos la respuesta entonces x es
el menor luego sigue z está en medio
luego y es el mayor comprobamos y listo